in this week's Fargo accessory first
turn to some new trailer drops and we
are heading back to your favorite
basement
oh the basement is all yours lights on
church on and no dancing no dancing
you're like the guy from Footloose
no dancing you guys
Netflix is updating the laughs for a new
decade in this teaser for That 70s Show
sequel series that 90s show will bring
back alums Kurt wood Smith and Deborah
Joe Rupp alongside a new cast of teens
you can stream the show on January 19th
next up from the 1990s to the 1920s
you'd be Mrs Dutton I would seems to
remain der I've acquired the Stratford
Ranch
well this is the Yellow Stone
and you have no rights here
Helen Mirren and Harrison Ford Star in
1923 the series is a prequel to
Yellowstone and serves as a sequel to
the series 1883. you can watch 1923 on
Paramount plus starting on December 18th
and now for what's opening in theaters
this weekend you're not so typical
holiday movie here's a look at violent
night
no my nice list
Santa Claus is Coming to Town
the film stars David Harbor as Santa and
when an elite team of mercenaries breaks
into a family Compound on Christmas eve
Santa is about to show why this Nick is
no saint here's a behind the scenes look
it's like two movies one this crazy
die-hard trapped in a house mercenaries
Vault underneath 300 million dollars and
then you have the Miracle on 34th Street
movie and they just sort of like smashed
together
violent night opens in theaters this
weekend and here to get us in the
festive yet spooky mood we have some fun
props from the studio and yes I am
getting in the festive spirit with my
Santa hat and we have some fun
gingerbread cookies there we go there's
my hat rocking the violent night hat
look they even sent over some
gingerbread cookies that are beheaded so
this movie I got the chance to screen it
last night and it's a combination of
action comedy of course some violence
and then that kind of fun holiday feel
they even make some references to Home
Alone which I really love so the movie
opens this weekend I wouldn't recommend
bringing your whole family this one's
just for the adults but definitely go
check it out it's it's fun it's great it
will keep you on the edge of your seat
the whole time that's it for this week's
from row access